who do you think uh I know it's still
early who do you think is going to run
and there's been a lot of people that
are like I'm because I remember when um
who's who's the girl that flipped
recently
people like maybe if you know the
Santa's gets it maybe there's been so
much like speculation what what do you
what do you think and what do you what
do you want and what do you think is
gonna happen I want uh DeSantis with
Tulsa gathered as the VP because she
brings women she'll bring Democrats
she'll bring the independence DeSantis
will bring the fire yes uh and we'll be
a unifier that's what I want well I
think will happen I think Trump will put
a run in it will be a massively split
issue and someone else will prevail but
I don't know who that is got you when
you say someone else you mean on the
left no so a different candidate would
make it through you're saying that if
Trump runs someone else could beat him
yes I believe that's true who do you
think could beat Trump well I mean I'm
the Foreigner aren't I they'll be just a
screaming okay
we've already known you have no no
problem sticking your toes in other
people's business so Why Stop Now who do
you think is going to be Trump well I
believe DeSantis could beat Trump
absolutely I don't think Pence could I
don't think a youngkin could yet he's
not well known enough I think Gavin
newsom's already picking out the kind of
drapes he thinks he's there right
gavinism is definitely already picking
up other people's skin that he could
wear in his [ __ ] American Psycho he
walked I don't know where Biden was
overseas somewhere Newsome took off his
jacket he's walking in the world he's
like oh yeah it's all set up he goes
with like a baby a baby come on bro
Biden's dogs they get out of there
you're not here it's formidable say
whatever you guys want he's formidable
he's marketable you know big enough
Newsome
[Music]
for sure guys he is I didn't tell I
didn't say anything about policies
anything you just said 80 of people in
America you know 80 of people you know
you have to look in themselves in the
mirror right so people people don't vote
based on policies people vote on who
looks good who sounds good who can give
a good one-liner who can give some
unfortunately that's how a lot of people
I totally agree with you yeah so how
people decide so that that guy is extra
to under the same way people
underestimated Trump who hate there's a
lot of people that hate Trump right and
they were underestimating him and people
people like yourself or Coulter or a lot
of people were going out there and
saying watch you're gonna eat your words
watch and you remember the day when they
announced the face
School schools were closed and they were
bringing uh emotional animals like pet
the zebra in the back because you're
gonna kill yourself and I think once
again I'm a comedian I went on stage in
Colorado and there was people like two
people in the back crying they were
bringing like sheep and dog and like
like emotional support animals to to
college universities because people
couldn't take it my favorite was when I
was watching CNN and they had to it was
on Election night when Trump had won
um which I'd like he did last time as
well but um yeah what he won and they
were trying to call Pennsylvania and it
was like they had some sort of facial
palsy because they just couldn't they
couldn't bring themselves yeah it was so
funny it was amazing so I said one thing
about Newsome not a California guy but
I've been pretty explicit about how that
cringy July 4th ad that he did oh yeah
uh he definitely looks the part
I'm not a big news and fam I actually
think he's annoying he definitely looks
the part good looking guy he's 6'3 by
the way Katie so that's you know not
short guys so you'll probably like him
well however if you slept with Kimberly
kilfoyle you're out already Donald Trump
Jr's current girlfriend so it's pretty
pathetic however he does look the part
so if you're just looking on Optics we
all know that situation with JFK versus
uh Nixon back in the day that if you're
listening on radio you were like well
Nixon won this but if you're watching on
TV JFK was the guy clearly so visual
unmarkability is a big thing I also
think on the flip side these days and
this is kudos to Trump and a lot of
people that you know why they like him
is
he's at least authentic and Gavin Newsom
strikes me as the least authentic just
cringy politician out there like hi I'm
here to tell you that like it's just so
phony and it's so fake and it's so
[ __ ] corny and inauthentic and I
think if you're just judging a book by
its cover he kind of has that Vibe but
if you actually listen to what he's got
going on I don't think the American
people okay here's my other questions um
and I and I I respect Adam because as
much as he hates Trump he can say
something like I understand why I like
Trump
but when you can say stuff like you
understand you got the policies you got
the it was the person it was the image
it was the cover of the book so that's
why I understand what you're saying with
Newsome and I was gonna ask you who
would if it's gonna be him and I thought
Biden says he's going to I don't think
so who's gonna run who's gonna be the
second one to go who's gonna who's the
second where so to try to be the
president of the Democrats on the left
on the left I have my idea
you're not saying Michelle well I think
it's Michelle runs
do you think she runs no I don't I don't
I'm I'm less than 10 on Michelle right
yeah and by the way I if if she if she
is asking friends and family like people
that and people that she values their
opinion
I don't know if you're gonna have a
better life than the one you do if it's
purely for history go for it but you're
young like go enjoy 30 they can enjoy 30
years of an unbelievable life at the
young age that they have
parties life enjoy they can do that now
if it's about history
Hillary's not in Michelle's League I
think Michelle can hold her own I think
she can talk she can communicate she can
sell she can edify yeah but I think
there's I think there's quietly behind
closed doors I don't know why is there
no chance Pat that I think we're on I
think this is the season this the season
for some you know out of nowhere
candidates to choose to run that
actually have a good chance to become a
nominee on the left uh I don't think on
the right I don't think on the right I
don't think anybody stands a chance to
be ahead of uh Trump in the sand but on
the left
I think Mark Cuban this is a good time I
think rock this is a good time although
he won't do it no I think uh Michelle
this is a fantastic time but I think
this is a season like even those
Hollywood stars and billionaires who
have a name for themselves this is a
very very good time I'll make a
prediction I think Cuban's gonna step
away from a apprentice and he's gonna go
spend time with his family
yeah I'm sorry a shark tank a shark tank
yeah and he's gonna come back and he's
gonna say after spending time my family
they've encouraged me to want to run
because they think America has a lot of
problems and they believe I can solve it
and I have a plan and all of a sudden in
the next nine 12 months you're gonna
hear her make an announcement Mark Cuban
I think so and by the way I tell you I
tell you one thing yeah I I um
he's a capitalist but he's also he's a
he's a liberal he's a guy on the left
but he's not a socialist he is a
capitalist uh
I think he has a chance to actually be
somebody on that side I fully agree with
you and I would vote for Mark Cuban as
far as that over a Biden or a trump or
anything divisive like that Cuban over
DeSantis
um I that I would genuinely want to see
them on the stage together and have an
unbiased General like gen like genuinely
curiosity curious mind to see what they
have to say I would actually appreciate
that let me let me put it through this
way
I didn't say I support I just said I
think they would run I'm not sitting
here telling you I'm supporting a uh a
Cuban running or not I'm not because he
still is a person that is gonna lean
more towards shutdown things like that
so just so you know like government laws
and all of that that is not something
that I'm I'm uh you know I think the
Santas will be like how Florida was
there in covet it's how America would be
if the census was president but just
think about that but if Cuban is
President and another covet happens it's
gonna happen what happened with uh the
shutdown but that's I want to ask you
guys you're bringing up Cuban because at
the end of the day you know that it's a
realistic possibility couldn't win
you're not saying it's not a far-fetched
idea no no I'm not saying I'm not saying
I would support or not I'm not saying
I'm not asking support you're saying
it's it's something that's feasible oh
let me play let me put it to you this
way he is a fool if he doesn't run
I'm telling you right now he's a fool if
he doesn't run if he's ever had which I
again gut feeling I don't know the guy
we don't have a relationship we've done
a you know one time I did an interview
with him and he was kind enough to uh
have me go to his office and American
Airlines we sat down we had a great
two-hour conversation brilliant guy
smart guy if he's ever
found the perfect opening to go run
today's attention and here's my question
I want to ask all of you guys if
somebody like him does come in is he
backing out of any of these policies
that we've been seeing for these two
years is the Border gonna get okay is
anything really going to change or he's
gonna just keep riding this train let me
let's not tell you what what I think he
would do he would actually talk to the
people like he would be on Twitter
saying he's going to give you his you
know what he believes needs to happen to
the Border he's not going to be hiding
okay but Cuban's not going to be hiding
you know how quickly he would respond to
an email I would send him like I
couldn't believe how quick he would
respond at two o'clock in the morning
one time I'm in our emailing each other
back 30 seconds boom 30 seconds back so
he is like he's like this he's on the
ball yeah he's he's he's a guy that will
actually circulate amongst the troops
like he'll fly out and go meet with
people he'll sit down he'll do those
types of things uh him but I think he's
going to be more Pro shutdown I think
he's going to be more Pro you know
control I think is going to be more Pro
that of the mindset and I think that
doesn't sit well with people who like
what the scientists got you and some
others that's why that's why I moved
here I moved here from four months ago
to come here work for patent I left
California and this is when you with the
saint is like you light up just like me
that's one of the main reasons that I
was like yeah I'll come here and that's
one of my things about Newsome is I get
that he's so marketable I get that he's
a brilliant speaker but half of
California or whatever is statistically
accurate leaving California that you
can't get a U-Haul truck to get you from
California to Florida anymore and you
can get paid to bring a U-Haul truck
back from Florida oh really yeah well
that's amazing the first time in 100
years they've had a net uh yeah so
what's the term net uh really net
vacancy whatever people leaving the
country so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]